my name is Peter Johnson I'm a
journalist a few days ago I decided to
investigate an old abandoned factory
claims of supernatural activity ghost
sightings have been very prolific on the
Internet
I began my investigation thinking I
could easily debunk this one but I was
wrong
I've already seen things that go against
all known signs and everything I thought
I knew I've tried to stay away since my
first encounter but I cannot it's like
something is calling me from deep down
that stairwell like a voice in the dark
as I entered the abyss Davis also enters
me
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play stairs now
this is actually a really really
interesting indie horror game that has
been made in the developers of the game
actually reached out to me so that I
could play it themselves but it's
available to everyone you can get it for
free on gamejolt this is the alpha build
so remember this is pretty early in
development but you will see that it's
far above and beyond like all the other
normal indie horror games that I play
besides Kraven Manor and oh man I'm
terrible with names but there was
another one that was really really high
quality so on
I'm actually pretty interested in
playing this and this isn't related to
SCP um Oh 8 9 or whatever the stairwell
one was just because it says stairs is
the name of the game does not mean that
they are that closely related or they
are and I have no idea either way from
what I saw in the screenshots it's not
just all about the stairwell see here we
are yeah
toldja told you as you can tell there
seem to be some other things going on
over here
geese guides rum can I go in here
squeaky hello yes you're gonna see from
what I saw in the screenshots that this
actually has tons of work put into it
and we are a paranormal investigator
apparently who decided that it was a
good idea to go into an abandoned
Factory
maybe these abandoned factories are
abandoned for a reason but reason does
not play a lot in these games your chunk
well that's a little bit better not much
though or any dead space monsters gonna
poke out of that vent over there okay no
all right it's eerily quiet now some
downer no okay can't quite see what I'm
doing and I don't really have an
immovable oh hi buddy how's it going
need a code to open it already then
where are you gonna find a code can't
open the lock oh everyone knows that
bathrooms are a bad idea in horror games
no matter what horror game it is no
matter where it is why it is there
bathrooms are a bad idea so why is this
one stall open is it the butt ghost
again but ghosts know there's nothing
gonna happen really huh I really like
the attention to detail that they put
into this game I mean obviously compared
to some of the indie horror games I
played any horror games the the quality
of the game that shelf is not that high
I'm not talking about just different
door codes oh yes it could
nice camera / - nice nice little touch
there at least it makes sense I'm able
to grab stuff from the environment okay
six one four one block yeah you are here
cool beans
alright is there anything else in this
room that I need and yes it's pronounced
rum not rum not room it's room ah get it
right just kidding everybody I know
people pronounce okay the bathroom
turned into amalga nation of horror haha
well let's see what happened here oh I
bet it's gonna be fun
oh do you need some privacy buddy
I'll just go away screw that uh open the
door I'm a monster I was like oh no I
would love to play a horror game where I
am the monster there's actually a thing
on Kickstarter where you do just that
thing but I would love to play one of
those games I think I'd be a great
monster just a multiplayer game where
you can hunt your friends that is
exactly the
I don't trust you I bet you're not there
oh no I just let out an unholy evil
unlike the world has ever seen before
I am here there's a bunch of black
squigglies and I'm assuming mark Shaw
areas where I cannot go man this these
shelves they're impenetrable I would
never be able to get through these this
is unreal okay
the challenge is insurmountable and I am
thoroughly confound it's been ages and
no one's come down here yet what I'm
going to do guys you need to sit tight
and wait don't come to get us when they
realize we've gone who's darker even be
outside the door oh I'm just minutes
from getting it open we just have to
wait I don't know how much more of this
I can take I say don't have anything
left to eat no nothing except each other
except nothing yeah nothing go check the
kitchen Samuel and me we'll check the
other okay that's no good but it's
starting to tell a really sinister story
here so the voices I heard were real but
just in the wrong time and I don't like
the look of these hallways here why am I
here don't um why am i down here which
way do I go that alway does not look
good I'm not going down that way no way
no hell
how hell hell I'm in how oh it's a glowy
thingy seriously there's that the amount
of work in this game is really really
well done this was made by a team of
eight on the Unreal development kit and
most of the games that I'd played on the
Unreal Engine have been superb quality
it must be a like I've never built any
game myself look at the exit door needs
a fuse of its own to work yeah well if I
could find these fuses and get out then
why couldn't these guys
we need to do something Samuel what do
you suggest I said there's nothing for
us to do yeah and what if it doesn't
come what then Samuel yes in what if L
comes but it's too late and we've
already started not gonna happen they're
gonna burst through the door get us
oh thanks L buddy I didn't do much
perceiving weeks until I find us and we
have to stay alive till then the poles
what about Jacob if we're going to live
we need to eat and the only thing left
to eat is Jacob ha ha oh goody
all right so we got a bit of a puzzle
here I'm guessing it needs to be pressed
in a certain order so these things
usually go by getting now they don't
seem to be staying up lit and have tried
a few combinations here um no okay there
may be some more oh there's more over
here of course
please don't seem to be powered so I'm
guessing I don't need to be here right
away but hello oh they opened doors I am
here I got you okay TGS oh seven let's
start with that one that's the closest
where'd my flashlight go thank you very
much okay so this door should be open
yes hello is anybody here is anybody
gonna pop out of me cuz if you are tell
me before you do so I can mentally
prepare myself okay okay this looks nice
and cheerful I love the way they
redecorated this place cuz use a bit
more blood though just spattered all
over the walls windows doorways down the
halls maybe seems to be something gluey
in there I'll need something to open the
vote ah I need a whole bunch of
something's don't tell me what I need
cuz I need a brain for one
there's nothing here I'm starting to
think we aren't getting you all this
place no no you're not
did you guys find anything no something
at least such a rescue gets here [ __ ]
really that's great what is it
yeah that's great with you yeah right
here right behind my back Isaac that's
Justin no hey what's that Oh blessed
Jacob in this hole nightmares huh and
then murder and then death and then
giant balls of flame burning in hell
okay anyway
Aziz pantomiming what it was actually
going on there hey what's that over
there
it seems to be glowing closes look at it
while someone sneaks up behind me with a
knife okay what do we got a loose bolt
handle should be a vault to use it on
somewhere cool I think that goes to that
thing that I saw before so let's put
this you know seven shut up [ __ ] do
this
we killed Jacob so hey Tim yeah Mike
isn't going to stop maasai stop unless I
kill him yeah I have to live always
whistles must die yeah exactly
duh you can't kill Isaac Isaac's too
smart for you what the hell is that with
that in my headphones there now these
are high quality headphones so sometimes
I can't tell sound plays such a crucial
role in Oregon's it as I can use this to
turn on the power and open some doors
okey-dokey is this guy swedish I don't
know if the developers are from Sweden
land so anyway there's this Isaac guy
and whatever the other guy's name is I
don't really care or no so either way
they're all murdering each other but I
bet there's one left
I bet there's still one left oh boy
these electronics are practically
ancient yes
I hope they still
cuz you know how those archaeologists
build up dig up ancient electronics all
the time
okay what's the next in your story I've
already got six and seven done looks
like ten and five are in the next areas
five leads to some 10 leads just back I
know where 10 goes but kitchens over
there and some question mark there so oh
I guess 10 would lead to oh no I could
get there anyway
or could I I have no idea but I'm gonna
try six or five five and the nine need
to be put in the same time I don't know
how to get them well let's just try five
four now maybe there's something in
there five alrighty so let's go out here
this way everybody follow me stick
together everybody hold hands if you
need to ha ha ha
hello it's dark in here
see this this is an example of how a
horror game should be very slow to start
it shouldn't just be about boom jump
scare that's not what makes a horror
game scary it's about the story has to
be there horror games have to have a
story even more so than other games
because the environment and where you
are in immersing yourself in what you're
doing is so important to everything
about a horror game it's absolutely in
central in this game is doing an
incredible job I mean for an alpha build
this is just damn fine work that they're
doing here so ok let me open up ten I
don't know oh I can get ah okay okay I
can get nine I can open all of them I
can open both nine and ten at the same
time I can just only open one of these
at the same time so let's open five
let's go through nine alright let's see
what we got so far nothing seems to want
to murder my face but I'm guessing that
once I get to that kitchen or the
question mark area things ain't gonna be
so friendly actually it all depends on
when the Alpha ends because I hope it
doesn't end too soon this is like this
is
what why no I am on there yeah I don't
wanna know that you wanna tea are you
Samantha real shadow what are you Wow
I see eyes open door nope okay
ah drug huh come on come on back back
back get closer
hmm
I didn't close it I don't even know if I
could which way do I go left which way I
go right
okay three here in here why why did I
come in here this is a bad idea
ah shadows on the walls okay we're gonna
be fine everybody we're gonna be fine
we're gonna be fine we're just running
from our doom as fast as we can is this
quiet question market oh no not another
bathroom what did I find
and I mean are a de Tolly babe i Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam did I get
him did I get him good I hope I got him
good I did didn't I ha ha ha ha ha ha
that's cool that was really cool I
really like that ha ha ha that was so
well done I love that oh man this is
this is really really an awesome an
awesome game that they put together here
it seems to be pretty damn amazing and I
have a theory as to why it is called
stairs is called stairs because there
are multiple levels to this if what they
have as I imagine for the vision of the
end game they're gonna be multiple
levels of this Factory if you have to go
into what is this oh that's the kitchen
I don't want to be in there they were
cooking up some human gumbo mm-hmm
that's good eating there but uh I think
I'll pass
oh hello I see
one fuse just one I need a total of six
if I recall they look like eyeballs yep
this could get me out of here
oh yeah oh oh hey these are new
Hey yeah man mmm
oh I would eat but I'm so full from
eating that dirt outside and uh yeah
choice cuts I mean really really supreme
I love that kidney there but uh yeah
good
it's okay that's nice
no no I do not
I'm thinking you know no nightmare
don't take me out of here no I would do
anything just
you know don't know ever been here nope
nope nope nope I don't care what you say
what you have to say what you think you
have to say I'm not gonna listen to a
word you say I am sick and tired of your
bull I'm not gonna take your bull
anymore but anyway it's just like this
is exactly what I've been talking about
in all the other world games this is
exact night good Peter
stay calm yeah my Peter was unleash like
you used to camera flash yeah about that
that's not a [ __ ] what what oh yeah oh
yeah boy die this is good this is good
oh man oh cool idea but holy crap
doesn't mean I have to like it
oh is it say the strong do what they can
the weak suffer one they must oh man
that is a cool effect I gotta say a
feast of bones oh good golly this is so
cool nothing left this so reminds me of
the cry for your opening accept and I
think this is a little well better done
this is a little this is a little more
well executed oh my goodness oh man I
hate the way in the shadows the blood
glints I was waiting for the walls to
suddenly be hah hah hah hah hah hah hah
to be covered with blood my god I don't
even know which way I'm supposed to go I
guess I follow the blood and the words
oh my god this is horrible had to live
not like that buddy not like that
there's no way to live
no way to live my friendly they have to
come who does hoo hoo hah go where we
had to we it seems like only one guy is
doing this horrible thing get out I'm
trying buddy
thanks for the encouraging words you're
such a motivation to improve myself wait
I can't move
I came up what Jesus Christ are you okay
sir
what who is that
where are they what are not there that
all a lie
was a lie wasn't it that was a lie
but the eyeball in this thing thong II
oh come on and then you and then the
game is just you follow the stairs down
and keep going into the abyss oh man I
guess you're gonna go up or down I'll go
down cuz I'm a glutton for punishment -
oh maybe I'm not Oh No yeah the stairs
suddenly end I guess they didn't think
that any sane person playing this game
would keep going down haha oh man oh
well can't flash anymore
I can flash the camera I didn't know
after this ordeal I took some time to
look up the case of Jacob Donner taken
by Cecchetti and Samuel Reid yarr Samuel
survived his fronts and was rescued yarr
but he brought something with him from
the darkness yarr soon after he regained
his freedom
Sammy Reid kidnapped and murdered an
eight-year-old boy took his body down to
the same shelter
and ate him well the authorities found
him he was sent to a mental hospital
where he still remains ha ha ha ha
five years ago yeah ha ha I don't know
why I was thinking of him as a Swedish
pirate but man that was something
special in case you noticed obviously I
didn't split this into two parts because
it was so short so in post I'm just
gonna stitch them together screw all
that other stuff that you heard you
probably didn't even hear it I don't
know what I'm gonna cut out yet but this
is all going to be in one part this was
amazing extremely well done
well executed a perfect example of what
horror should be takes itself completely
seriously doesn't throw cheap jump
scares at you there was like one jump
scare in that whole thing and it fit
because you expected when you're
flashing in the darkness something's
gonna pop out of you at some point down
there so much creepiness just soaked
into the walls of that game that was
amazing and it was just the demo I would
pay ten dollars or more for the full
game I would pay money depending on how
long it is I would gladly pay money for
this game the developers did an
incredible job go see the website in the
link below on our website it's all
linked to gamejolt um man this is just
extremely well done it's what I say
every time I play a game that doesn't
live up to my standards this is an
example of what I mean and what horse
should be this is so well done so play
it for yourselves give it a try I don't
think I actually explored all the rooms
there I think there was more stuff that
I could have seen maybe I'm not exactly
sure but give it a try for yourselves
try it but headphones on played in the
dark complete darkness and so that
random noises of your apartment or house
to get to yeah so anyway thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotations for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
now
Oh
yeah